last week out of nowhere on Friday
president Trump put something on Truth
social if you can put this up and then
we can go through a couple of the tweets
and I'll you know speculate on why I
think that happened but if you want to
put up what the president said about uh
uh about vivec last week on truth I
think that's what it is vivec started
his campaign as a great supporter the
best president Generations Etc
unfortunately now all he does is
disguise his support in the form of a
deceitful campaign tricks very Sly but a
vote for vvec is a vote for the other
side don't get do by this vote for Trump
don't waste your vote Vic is not Mega
the Biden indictment indictment against
his political opponent will never be
allowed in this country they are already
beginning to fall Mega